another week another trip to westeros
that's what i say and before we get
started i do want to thank the sponsor
of this video this video is brought to
you by raycon earbuds raycon earbuds are
those slick stylish true wireless
earbuds that come in about half the
price of the competition and still crank
out that sound they have optimized gel
tips for a snug fit they're not gonna
fall out of your head and holding in the
left button on the left earbud for three
seconds allowing you to cycle through
the different sound options that was a
game changer for these earbuds for me
between pure sound balance sound and
bass sound these earbuds literally live
in my ears they still are my workout
earbuds but not just that great for
going on walks just technically still
light cardio listening to music
listening to audiobooks i will go to bed
and fall asleep with these things in my
ears playing soft meditative music and
raycon earbuds offer wireless charging
capability props convenience is never
overrated so click the link below go to
buy recon.com john's get yourself 15 off
your purchase and now we talk about the
newest episode of that weekly series
that teaches us that true drama comes
from that place that vin diesel could
never fathom it does family and in this
week what is this episode four yep it's
episode four it's one of those rare
cases i thought it was longer this is
great it means more episodes to talk
about but the suitors keep pouring in
the aladdin parable keeps going through
this episode even to the point where
rinera dresses like a civilian a
commoner goes into the streets at night
i mean well
i saw some stuff i never saw in aladdin
you know what i loved is this episode
started out on the right foot for me
when all the suitors are coming to her
and there's that little kid you know
little milhouse
that what other dude was talking [ __ ]
they get into a fight you just straight
up guts the bully i was like
oh i don't even care i'll start the slow
clap there's my living room no one's
here but me he shall now be knighted sir
thrill house first of his name a dame
and targaryen the prodigal returns with
a fresh new haircut and of course it's
just a presence
he's the guy's a [ __ ] magnet him just
being in king's landing and being
himself
leads to things just getting stressful
for those in charge because damon
targaryen was like oh rinera let's go
out there and i'll show you the
nightlife of the place we
we live in and yeah she uh she sees some
things they do some things they were
almost gonna do more things and then he
got pissed and smacked the wall and was
like i'm not gonna do those things it's
kind of funny in a scene like that where
i'm like
why did he stop hmm let's analyze that's
why westeros is different than other
shows a lot of other shows just like oh
a sex scene skin let's lock in for that
not in westeros westeros you're like hmm
let's analyze this well why is this
happening what are his angles what are
his hidden agendas this is important
stuff yeah when he stopped i was forced
to be like did he stop because he cares
and just doesn't want to cross that line
or is he thinking other more official
channels to go through for me to get
that precious precious throne and of
course ronero was like i'm worked up um
you will totally work you got the look
you got the armor you got the hair you
look like
prince charming from shrek let's just do
this but this whole episode is about
rumors and it's not about what happened
it's about perception of what happened
we could all learn a thing or two about
that you know social media it's real
well my social media is what i thought
of when renera and damon targaryen they
were watching that play and it was just
like oh and renero targaryen the air to
the throne everyone's like boo i was
like oh man this is like what it was
like going on twitter for her but back
then back then this could be the year
3047 to that it's like the technology
never really advances that's how fantasy
roles unless it's warhammer 40k in which
case will they get there in this episode
they were mindful they were like okay
we forgot to cgi take away a couple of
king viserys's fingers let's let's not
do that this time we got a couple of
close-ups we got to make sure those
gangrenous cgi fingers are gone also
yeah you see all the boils and swords
what all of that sorry is this you know
with the the king and the queen were
getting down it was just like his gross
decayed body
on hers and i'm like that's one way to
show us all the king's sores and all the
king's men man that dude is falling
apart just straight up it was kind of
funny to me when that little kid told
otto hightower about renera and damon
targaryen being in that pleasure house i
was like oh even otto hightower he has
his little birds and he was like with
this information i will do what i do
best
i'm telling and the interesting thing
for me in that situation is how pissed
off viserys got you know i mean any dad
would but they're targaryens it's easy
to hear about incest among the
targaryens be like oh yeah they're all
totally cooling down with it even when
it was like oh see snake's daughter what
are the positives that dude's like well
she has targaryen blood
that's good but it was a cool angle to
see like no no there are lines that
targaryens don't cross even if
targaryens of the past crossed it we
don't cross it now damon targaryen seems
completely cool with it but viserys was
like no i am glad that viserys put two
and two together with otto hightower
sometimes people do calculated moves and
everyone around them can see something
that they can't see kind of like a
person climbing a mountain a person
climbing a mountain has a relationship
with that mountain and that experience
that onlookers can't feel however an
onlooker can see a broader picture of
the mountain the foothills as a whole
they can see
the bigger picture to a degree that the
person climbing the mountain just can't
see because of tunnel vision two
different perspectives it's probably
easier for people back here to see that
otto hightower is a manipulative little
prick i'm glad that king viserys was
like
nope i'm gonna
take that little symbol the hand of the
king someone else will get it thank you
for your service i do like what he said
though where he was like you've served
the realm the realm has a debt to you
that cannot be repaid it's like that
phrase both can be true it's like yep he
was a good hand to the king at one time
also king can't trust him now so that
has to go to someone else now who's
going to be the next hand of the king i
think it should be that dude that's
actually given him council on a couple
of occasions smart forthcoming he will
be a great hand to the king until the
position corrupts him as it does all
people hand of the king's diapers and
politicians should all be changed often
and for the same reason but it was
another episode of house of the dragon
in which if you are looking for fights
and excitement and war all the time this
is not it political scheming maneuvering
navigating though this one was a more
personal story when it came to renera
targaryen all of them have had her at
the center but this there's something
about this one where she was just like i
uh i'm gonna go see what the nightlife
is like
wow between that and her father giving
like reaffirming the story like look all
right there's a story in this dagger if
you heat it up and fire it's like the
ring
but it's a dagger it's very important
work we're doing here it's not just a
title pulled myself away from cobra kai
season 5 to watch house of the dragon do
a video and this has actually been a
pretty pretty fun day of binging
watching and enjoying also house of the
dragon episode 4 have you seen it what
did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]
you